Republican leaders made a promise to
finish tax reform by Christmas the clock
is ticking in their plans just hit a
major stumbling block Republican
senators Marco Rubio and Mike Lee object
to the size of a tax credit for
low-income children so that means the
GOP has not nailed down enough votes to
pass the overhaul Rubio says he'll vote
no if that credit isn't increased Lee is
officially undecided president Trump and
other GOP leaders say they can work out
the problem but there are other
challenges including the health of two
key Republicans Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with the latest obstacles
to tax reform Nancy good morning good
morning Republicans are planning to
unveil the text of their bill later
today so that people can actually read
it before they hold what they hope will
be a vote as early as Monday but in the
meantime they have run into several
significant problems with no easy
solutions Republican leaders are
scrambling after Florida's Marco Rubio
and Utah's Mike Lee issued an ultimatum
they're demanding that the refundable
child tax credit be increased by more
than a hundred dollars an earlier bill
would have doubled it unless they can
figure out a way to add to the 1100
figure I won't support the bill
Tennessee's bob Corker could also be a
no he's worried about what the bill
could do to the debt are you and then
there are the two Republican senators
who are ailing and have missed votes all
week Arizona's John McCain and
Mississippi's thad Cochran vice
president Mike Pence is delaying a trip
to Jerusalem in Casey's needed to break
a tie it's all about timing and managing
absences in the Senate there could also
be an issue with Senate rules the plan
can't cost more than 1.5 trillion
dollars but this version appears to be
even more expensive than the last public
knows it's awful Democrats argue the
bill is a giveaway to big businesses
that are already thriving it permanently
slashes the corporate tax rate and does
not close many corporate loopholes as
Republicans initially promised it's a
monumental con job the individual rate
cuts on the other hand are
set to sunset after 2025 and Republicans
are now considering moving that date up
to save money this is being rushed to
judgment and the American people by
substantial numbers believe this bill is
not good for them these Republican
challenges do not get any easier if they
buy themselves some time in a couple of
weeks they are going to lose a Senate
seat due to that Democratic win in the
Alabama Senate race and so Galle they
are really working to figure out what
they can do right now you know they are
scrambling thank you very much Nancy
John do you think Republican senators
could really vote against the bill or is
this just all for show well corker of
Tennessee already voted against the
Senate version so he's he's probably
where he's gonna be Marco Rubio it's a
little bit he's getting some negotiating
out of this it's a surprise that more
senators don't do this you get a lot of
attention you get gift baskets you get
what you want when you're when you're
the person but what's interesting about
what Rubio and Lee are doing is they are
in a sense focusing the last mile here
on this new legislation on this notion
that basically a lot of the benefits of
this tax package go to either the
wealthy or to corporations why not a
little bit something for the working
poor it kind of crystallizes at the last
moment here and argument Democrats have
been making about this bill but when it
comes to actually vote what do you think
they'll do well I don't I don't predict
Gale especially in this political
climate but it is a real challenge for
all those timing reasons that that Nancy
suggested which means I think we'll have
a little burst of excitement here at the
end and the president is putting a lot
of pressure on them too he sure is he
sure see if he's a Salesman well done